hello again so in the first part of the
lecture we had seen that in this third
week we are interested in discussion the
transformation of stresses and as a
first headway into that discussion we
had very briefly recapped the concept of
stress at the state of stress at a point
and the point that I had highlighted at
the very end of that part one of the
lecture is that the state of stress that
is the components of stress which appear
at a particular point depends very much
on the choice of the coordinate axis
that we use so let's put that down in
writing
this basically means that if we use
different sets of coordinate axes then
the values of the various stress
components will come out to be different
or various different choices of the
coordinate axes
the values of the stress components
we'll come out to be different
what we mean to say in other words is
that suppose we have one set of
coordinate axes as x y&z
and suppose the stress components refer
to this our Sigma xx Sigma YY Sigma said
said tau XY tau Y Z tau ZX and suppose
we use a different set of coordinate
axes x - y - set - then Sigma X - X dash
Sigma y dash y dash Sigma set - set -
doubt X dash y dash y dash said - and
tau Z dash X dash will be the stress
components refer to this new set of
coordinate axes now in general Sigma xx
will never be equal to Sigma X - x -
Sigma YY will never be equal to Sigma Y
- y - and so on and so forth so again to
emphasize the point that I had been
making all along it really does depend
on what coordinate axis you have chosen
to work out your problem but despite
this apparent difficulty what is true
however and this is very very important
and what what this chapter is really all
about is that once you have the
information about the stress components
in one particular coordinate system it
is very much possible to mathematically
obtain the stress components in another
coordinate system so if you know if you
actually know the values of Sigma xx
Sigma YY Sigma ZZ
tau XY tau Y Z and tau ZX and you know
how what is the relationship that
between X dash y dash Z Dash and x y&z
so perhaps this this way of depicting
the coordinate axis is a little bit
misleading what I mean to say is that
suppose it is the situation is like this
that you have X Y and set like this and
you have your X dash y dash and said -
like this then you'll of course move
what is the relative orientation of X -
with the other axis XY and said what is
the relative orientation of y dash with
x y&z and what is the relative
orientation of set - with x y&z with
these three pieces of information you
can actually go about finding out the
values of Sigma X - x - signal y - y
their signals etc etc and you don't have
to measure them separately you can
actually find them mathematically and
this this transformation of stress
chapter is where we are going to learn
how to do this of course our doing this
three-dimensional case is a little bit
challenging and beyond the scope of our
first-year mechanics syllabus so what we
are going to learn is to reduce our
reduce the complexity of this challenge
by considering a two-dimensional version
of this problem so
so here in our first year we'll focus on
transformation of stress into D so
specifically what we are going to do
we are going to consider
a state of stress where Sigma xx Sigma
YY Sigma XY are not zero in general but
Sigma's said said Sigma X said and Sigma
Y said or equivalently Sigma said said
tau X said tau wise it will be zero this
is very very important so this kind of
state of stress is usually referred to
as a plane stress
they should refer to as plane stress so
all the examples of the explanations all
the derivations that we'll be doing will
be focused on this kind of plane stress
so we no longer have to consider a
three-dimensional state of stress we no
longer have to consider a three
dimensional body rather we'll focus our
entire attention on two-dimensional
things so what we want to do is consider
a body like this it did not be a perfect
square like this it could have a general
two dimensional shape but for
convenience what we are doing is
considering a very small area around a
point in a in a general theta in a
general two-dimensional body and we can
have on our axis like this x and y and
we know that this will be all Sigma xx
this will be our Sigma X Y or tau XY
this will be our Sigma YY this is tau XY
this also will be Sigma YY this is Sigma
xx
this is Dow XY
and this is tau XY also so we are going
to look at transformation of stresses
from this coordinate system from the XY
coordinate system to another coordinate
system maybe an x - y - coordinate
system considering the same original
two-dimensional body with the
understanding that we know have we have
full information about the relative
orientations of X Dash and y dash with
the x and y coordinate axis so that will
be the discussion in the next part of
our lecture